bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire le septième de
la série et ce soir nous allons
poursuivre sur la thématique de la
régression logistique que nous avions
abordé la semaine dernière puisque la
semaine dernière nous avions abordé la
régression logistique y binaire donc
nous allons repartir du travail de la
semaine dernière nous avions fait notre
premier modèle et puis nous allons
aborder quelques points supplémentaires
par rapport à la régression d'une part
est ce qu'on peut avoir une paix valeur
pour tester l'effet global d'une
variable est ce qu'il est possible
d'améliorer notre modèle et on va voir
notamment comment est-ce qu'on peut le
faire par minimisation de la hisser dans
une démarche descendante pas à pas on
abordera les effets d'interaction et la
question de la multi co linéarité et si
on a un petit peu de temps on abordera
la régression logistique multi nominal
et la régression logistique ordinale
comme à chaque fois et bien écoutez on
va déjà chargé notre ère studio la voyez
je suis je viens de démarrer un studio
du coup j'ai une invitation de r dans ma
console vous le voyez je n'ai aucun
projet actuellement d'ouvert est ce que
je vais faire
j'avais du coup recharger le projet de
la semaine dernière puisque on va
repartir de ce qu'on a fait la semaine
dernière
alors je l'avais appelé webinaire 06
donc je vais cliquez ici
et donc du coup air studio va se
recharger mais en se positionnant dans
le cadre du coût du projet en question
d'une part vous pouvez le voir ici il a
changé le répertoire de travail pour se
repositionner dans le répertoire
du projet et je peux le voir sous
l'onglet files où j'ai les différents
fichiers de mon projet qui sont là et un
studio se souvenait qu'on avait dit
ouvert à ce moment là le script analyse
pratique sport.es ray voyez il va ré
ouvert le script au même endroit et puis
il m'a recharger l'état de mon
environnement à cette étape là ce que je
vais faire malgré tout haut pour pouvoir
me remettre dans la situation la semaine
dernière je vais tout simplement effacé
tous les objets que j'avais en mémoire
et puis je verrai exécuté mon script
intégralement comme ça on sera vraiment
dans la même situation que la semaine
dernière donc un clic ici sur sources me
permet de re exécuter tout un script il
est en train du coup de s'exécuter et
donc du coup ça va me permettre de
recharger les package dont j'ai besoin
en mémoire il va me reconstruire va me
rées apporter mes données reconstruire
mon modèle logistique
donc il va exécuter tous les éléments et
puis et puis faire les calculs on voyait
le script bien se dérouler intégralement
en fait il a refait tous ces éléments là
et notamment l'huma réimporter h début
2003 il m'a fait les corrections sur les
variables que l'on avait fait jusque là
puis il a calculé mon modèle logistique
qui s'appelle mode
je vous rappelle le modèle donc si je la
fiche dans la console le modèle en
question que nous avions calculé
la semaine dernière c'était donc un
modèle de régression logistique binaire
donc c'est un modèle linéaire
généralisée jlm avec family égale
binomiale et à partir du coût des
données de l'enquète histoires de vie
2003 nous avions regardé la probabilité
de faire du sport donc sport quoditien
oui non en fonction du groupe d'âge du
sexe du niveau d'études du rapport à la
religion et puis d'une variable continu
qui était le nombre moyen passé devant
la télévision par jour
vous voyez ici le coefficient du modèle
mais on avait vu que pour une
présentation plus efficace on pouvait
avoir recours à la fonction tibet
l'immolation du package et tissot mairie
si j'exécute la commande
ça va me faire un tableau de mon modèle
donc on a ici vu que j'ai passés
exponentielle car le clou on a du coup
les les opérations l'exponentielle des
coefficients leur intervalle de
confiance à 95 %
et puis l'épée valeur on peut aussi se
représenter ça de manière plus graphique
grâce à la fonction gg coeff modèle du
package et girly encore une fois ce
paramètre exponentielle des gardes trou
parce que c'est un modèle de régression
logistique et donc que je préfère
représenter les ratios et donc si on
regarde le graphique obtenu je vais
faire un zoom donc les textes ont
peut-être écrit un petit peu petit mais
ce que l'on voit vous avez d'abord les
faits sur le groupe d'âge donc 18 24 ans
emma modalités de référence on voit que
la pratique du sport diminue au fur et à
mesure que l'on avance en âge
concernant le ratio associé au groupe
d'âge 25 44 ans eh bien voyez qu'on ait
des intervalles de confiance qui sont
assez larges et qui recoupe la ligne des
1 et donc on a une valeur de 0,07
ce qui nous dit que fondamentalement
cette aux ratios là n'est pas
statistiquement signifier n'est pas
significativement différent d'eux c'est
aux ratios là autrement dit que cela va
leur ici n'est pas fondamentalement
différente de 1 même si on est à la
limite de la significativité 1 et on
voit bien l'autre ratio les intérêts de
confiance qui sont vraiment sûrs sur le
bord par contre concernant les groupes
d'âge 45 59 ans et 60 ans et plus on a
des hôtes ratio qui sont clairement
différent de 1 donc sont clairement
différents de ceux des 18 24 ans avec dp
valeurs qui sont extrêmement faibles
on est ici sur un effet qui est quand
même particulièrement visible un plus on
avance en âge
- on pratique du sport et même si c'est
aux ratios là sur le bord de la
significativité on voit bien en tout cas
un effet clairement mckidd plus long
pour le sexe la référence sont les
femmes et les hommes pratiquent plus le
sport que les femmes et on l'a on a une
valeur inférieure à un pour mille donc
un effet clairement significatif au
niveau d'études
on voit que la pratique du sport
augmente avec le niveau d'études
primaire secondaire supérieur avec du
coup le niveau technique professionnelle
qui est proche du secondaire et puis le
nil et manquant donc ce qui en général
pas terminé leurs études qui sont plus
proches du niveau supérieur
donc ça ce sont des effets à âge égal et
on voit bien du coup un qui a des effets
qui sont marquées concernant le rapport
à la religion
eh bien tous les autres ratio monde
épais valeur supérieure à 5% donc ce qui
est indiqué sur ce graphique 1 par le
fait que ce sont des cercles avec un
point blanc l'intérieur par défaut un
gkf modèle vous distingue les zones
ratio significatif des zones ratio non
significatif est donc là on voit bien
que tous les autres à sion des
intervalles de confiance large qui
regroupe la ligne d un ânon globalement
il n'y a pas d'effet marqué du rapport à
la religion sur la pratique du sport
et puis on voit ensuite la variable hors
quotidienne de télévision donc c'est une
variable qui rentrait dans le modèle de
manière continue et d'oncle aux ratios
que vous avez ici c'est l'effet pour
chaque coeur additionnel passé devant la
télévision
autrement dit ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que quand on passe du temps dans
télévision un peu une heure de plus on a
une probité de faire du sport qui est
plus faible mais ça ça augmente à chaque
fois qu'on rajoute une heure de
télévision par jour 1 les effets se
cumulent donc ça c'est ce que nous
avions vu la semaine dernière
alors il est évident un pour le sexe
qu'il variable binaire qu'on peut dire
que le sexe a un effet significatif sur
la pratique du
or puisque on a un seul coefficient
cette ode ratio qui est là donc on a
bien une paix valeurs qui marque et de
même on peut répondre facilement à la
question de savoir est ce que le nombre
d'heures passées devant la télévision
un effet sur la pratique du sport là
encore on a un seul coefficient par
contre quand il s'agit de l'ajout de la
pratique religieuse c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué pour la pratique
religieuse on voit qu'aucun des zones
rationner différent de 1,1 avec les
intervalles de confiance sont larges
donc on se doute bien qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet de la pratique du rapport à la
religion sur la pratique du sport
mais il serait intéressant d'avoir une
paix valeurs qui me disent l'effet
global de la variable de la même manière
pour le groupe d'âge c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué parce que seulement 2 des
zones ratio sur trois sont significatifs
donc encore une fois ce qui sera
important pour nous c'est de savoir y at
il un effet global de la variable
groupes d'âge
alors pour regarder l'effet global d'une
variable on peut faire ce qu'on appelle
une analyse de la variance le principe
c'est convard calculé à un modèle avec
ou sans la variable on va regarder si
les deux modèles diffèrent
significativement et on aura du coup une
telle valeur globale
je vais vous montrer trois manières de
faire la chose les deux premières je
vais faire dans la console
donc c'est de passer par la fonction
droit poigne qu'une fonction générique
de air base et donc si je fêterai poigne
et je lui passe mon modèle qu'il va
faire ça qui va
tester les différents modèles on retire
les variables une à une
sauf que là j'ai pas de paix valeur il
faut que je rajoute l'option test égale
qui secouèrent je crois voilà donc le
principe pour bien comprendre les
résultats c'est mon modèle de base dont
celui ci à 1 a hissé de 2236 on avait
déjà abordé rapidement la hisser la
hisser ces mesures de compromis entre la
vraisemblance et le nombre de degrés de
liberté et vous avez les résidus du
modèle qui sont de 2206 donc ça plus la
déviance va être petit l'on va réduire
les résidus plus le modèle sera bon en
terme de prédiction
si je prends la variable groupe âge
si je prends la variable groupes d'âge
donc l'idée ici c'est que on va re
calcul est un modèle 100 groupes d'âge
donc ça serait sport en fonction de sexe
est une religion et rtv si je retire la
variable groupe d'âge mon modèle à ce
moment là on a les résidus augmente de
manière importante puisqu'on passe 2206
à 2259 et donc on va pouvoir faire un
test statistique pour savoir si le
modèle 100 groupes d'âge et
significativement différent du modèle
avec le groupe d'âge et j'obtiens cette
valeur 2 76e - 11
donc pour rappel l'écriture e - on se
dira fois dix puissance moins 11 donc
ces 2 76 x 10 puissance moins on c'est à
dire qu'on décale 1,2 aux chiffres vers
la gauche et donc on a un nombre qui est
extrêmement petit on est largement en
dessous du un pour mille donc il ya bien
un effet significatif du groupe d'âge et
là j'ai une [ __ ] wah qui s'applique à
l'ensemble de mon groupe d'âge
si je prends ici c'est que sebbah l'idée
c'est qu'on fait la même chose dont je
reprends un modèle qui serait sport en
fonction de groupes d'âge études
religieuses tv donc sans le sexe pareil
on voit que les résidus passe de 2206 à
2224 et on a encore une fois une paix
valeur extrêmement petit ça veut dire
que si je retire le sexe du modèle jeu
je perds beaucoup en explications et
donc il ya bien un effet significatif du
sexe par contre si je prends la religion
nous faisons maintenant un modèle qui ne
contient pas la religion donc ça serait
sport en fonction du groupe d'âge du
sexe des études et 2h tv à ce moment là
des coûts retire une variable bien sûr
on va perdre un peu en termes explicatif
on passe de 2206 à 2211 de résidus donc
on les résidus augmente on a un petit
peu moins on explique un petit peu moins
de variance mais le test est de 0,5 ça
ne dit que fondamentalement on explique
on exprime on explique à peu près autant
de variance avec la religion que sans la
religion
ce que nous dit le test c'est que kylie
et la religion ou pas dans le modèle
finalement les écarts sont équivalents
de 1200 j'ai à peu près proches 2206 8
soit 2207 et donc on peut dire
globalement il n'y a pas d'effet de la
religion sur la pratique du sport
donc vous voyez en passant par dhr
poitns obtiennent des valeurs qui me
donne un effet global de la variable
pour savoir est ce que ma variable a
globalement un effet sur mon à haute
comme ici la probité de faire du sport
une fonction un petit peu plus un petit
peu plus
avancée pour calculer ses effets glow
globaux c'est la fonction à nova du
package car donc si je charge
l'extension car je vais charger du coup
la fonction à nova avec une majuscule
attention il ya deux fonctions à nova
avec une minuscule c'est la fonction de
base en stats qui est un petit peu
différente qui fait pas tout à fait la
même chose et vous avez la fonction à
nova avec un a majuscule du package cas
donc une version améliorée de droit
points et qui couvre un plus grand
nombre de types de modèles
donc si je fais à nova de mode en fait
j'obtiens donc à présent les mêmes
résultats juste présenter un tout petit
peu différemment mais grosso modo j'ai
bien l'effet global de chacune de mes
variable alors quand vous avez des
interactions dans un modèle des types de
contraste il ya trois types de tests le
type 1 qui est celui qui fait par un
drop one le type 2 qui est fait par
défaut avec la fonction à nova et le
type 3 retenez que pour vous type 1 type
de type 3 dans le cas présent sur ce
type de modèle à ça ne change pas grand
chose
disons que lorsque vous avez des effets
d'interaction il vaut mieux utiliser des
types 3
si vous n'avez pas d'effet d'interaction
et qu'on a des contrats de type
traitement il faut mieux dé type 2 mais
pour la plupart des modèles que vous
ferez est engouffré pas des modèles très
avancées en fait vous aurez les mêmes
résultats
donc j'ai envie de dire sachez qu'il ya
plusieurs types et on y est on y vous y
reviendrez éventuellement un jour où
vous aurez des modèles plus complexe et
il y aura besoin de se frotter à la
question de ces types là alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est que jti se marie à
une fonction qui va nous permettre de
rajouter les effets globaux directement
à notre tableau celui ci est rajouté cp
valeur globale
donc je vais reprendre ici le code du
tableau
[Musique]
et je vais rajouter la fonction had
global pis si j'exécute cette commande
ça me rajoute à mon tableau dans la
colonne des valeurs cp valeur globale
juste pour l'information on vous
explique en dessous là dans le message à
l'écran que c'est calculé avec la
fonction car à nova et en utilisant le
type croire et dans la fonction at
global pays vous pouvez choisir le type
de type 3 mais encore une fois pour le
moment ça vous concerne pas vraiment
quand on rajoute à global pis vous
n'ayez plus que l'épée valeur globale
l'accord de chaque variable donc on voit
qu un effet global du groupe d'âge du
sexe du niveau d'études et que le
rapport à religion n'a pas d'effet
significatif si vous souhaitez conserver
à la fois l'épée valeur individuelle de
chaque coefficient plus l'été valeur
globale
il ya une option alors pour ça on
regarde l'aide de had global opi
d'accord et vous avez l'option keep kivu
par défaut farce et qui sont la passat
show permet de garder les valeurs
individuelles
donc si je fais à global opi keep égale
creux à ce moment là dans mon tableau
j'aurai à la fois l'épée valeur globale
qui sont affichées en face du nom des
variables et l'épée valeur individuelle
de chaque coefficient pour ma variable
numérique heures tv il n'ya pas à s'en
soucier c'est qu'en fait c'est la même
valeur pour les variables qui sont
numériques d'accord
qui du coup ont un seul coefficient la
valeur du coefficient où la valeur
globale sont les mêmes et donc on a bien
à cette information comme quoi les faits
significatifs alors une question qui est
posée dans le chat c'est à partir de
combien de chiffres après la virgule
l'affluence de la variable est
significative alors c'est pas une
question de chiffres après la virgule en
tant que tel c'est comme pour tout
statistiques à partir de quelles valeurs
du petit p ô considère qu' un effet
significatif lusage le plus fréquent
c'est de considérer qu'il y a un effet
significatif si le petit p est
inférieure à 5%
un petit p inférieur à 5% ça veut dire
qu'il ya une chance sur 20 qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule chance sur 20 que l'on se
trompe autrement dit que l'on conclut un
effet significatif alors qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet significatif
ce qui est certain c'est que quand votre
petit p est inférieure à 1%
il n'y a plus qu'une chance sur 100 que
l'on que l'on se trompe c'est à dire il
ya plus qu'une chance sur cent qu'on
dise qu'ils aient un effet significatif
alors qu'en fait il n'y en a pas et
quand le petit pays est inférieur à un
pour mille
là on a quelque chose qui est clairement
significatif donc lusage c'est de
regarder la significativité à 5% mais
c'est vrai que si la variable à une
significativité élevée à 1% voire un
pour mille on est beaucoup plus serein
avec notre résultat qu'avec un niveau de
significativité à 5% ce qui peut aussi
arriver on sait si je reviens cette fois
ci au petit p qui compare les 25 44 18
24 ici on est à 7 % donc 7% c'est
au-dessus de la significativité mais si
nos effectifs sont faibles
parfois on va regarder les variables qui
sont significatives à 10% ce qui est
local pour le coup ici l'effet d'ajdir
c'est un effet qui est le même c'est pas
que c'est les zones ratio baisse tout du
long l'effet croissant par rapport à la
jaille d'une sorte de cohérence
donc on peut être confiant sur ses
effets de l'âge sur la pratique du sport
si j'avais eu un effet uniquement les 25
44 et pas des 45 59 des 60 et plus et
qu'on voyait juste un effet sur ce
groupe d'âge
j'aurais probablement été plus nuancé
dans mon interprétation
encore une fois il ya la manière
d'interpréter au delà de est
significatif on pas significatif
on peut avoir des nuances entre des
variables qui sont hautement
significative avec dp valeur inférieure
à un pour mille
et puis des variables qui sont un peu
aux limites de significativité et qui
sont entre 4 et 7% de significativité
peut-être qu'on va nous lancer un petit
peu nos résultats à la manière dont
valeo dont on va d interpréter alors je
vois qu'il ya un message qui est posée
sur un message d'erreur sur un argument
inutilisés là ce que je vois c'est que
votre syntaxe est fausse puisque cead
estimate touristes ou égal au jeu je
vois pas voulu ou vous le mettez je
pense que vous avez quelque part une
erreur dans votre syntaxe vous voulez
vous qu'à la regarder de manière plus
plus précise peut-être que vous n'avez
pas une version récente de jti se marie
si vous n'avez pas la verser dernière
version vous n'avez pas encore l'option
à d'estimé sur le feu en soi qui arrivé
il ya peu dans tous les cas ce genre de
questions particulières ont les abordera
la semaine prochaine puisque la semaine
prochaine nous aurons une question de
une session de foire aux questions qu'il
a aura lieu sur zoom et donc du coup on
pourra se parler de vive voix et surtout
pourrait partager votre écran pour qu'on
puisse vraiment repérer d'où vient le
message d'erreur là on est sur ce type
de message d'erreur sur lesquels je peux
difficilement répondre si j'ai pas votre
écran sous les yeux donc nous avons vu
qu'on pouvait assez facilement avoir un
effet global de chaque variable
la question c'est faut-il garder toutes
les variables dans le modèle est en soi
c'est une vraie question et tout dépend
des objectifs de votre
de votre modèle dans certains cas ainsi
ma question principale c'est de savoir
est ce qu'il y a un effet de la religion
sur la pratique du sport et j'utilisais
variable âge sexe niveau d'étude comme
des variables de contrôle je vais garder
à variable aux religions dans mon modèle
parce que j'ai une hypothèse en amont
qui serait que cette variable aurait en
effet et là je peux montrer qu'elle n'a
pas d'effet dans d'autres cas de figure
on est plutôt dans des approches on va
chercher les facteurs associés à la
pratique du sport il est donc en fait on
va partir d'une quinzaine d'une
trentaine de variables en amont et on
veut trouver celle qui rompt le plus
d'effet on sait qu'ils vont jouer dessus
or un modèle où il ya trop de variables
c'est un modèle qui est parfois un peu
instable et c'est pas forcément le
meilleur modèle pour expliquer notre
phénomène
donc si jamais on est dans une démarche
où on va partir d'un grand nombre de
variables souvent la première chose que
l'on va faire c'est de revenir à
l'analyse vivarié on l'avait fait la
semaine dernière joue appel je vous
montre le tableau on analyse by variés
donc si on a il préidentifiée je sais
pas moi 20-25 variables explicatives
potentiel fait d'abord l'analyse vivarié
ai commencé à regarder celles qui ont un
effet en bi variés une pratique assez
fréquente c'est de retenir à ce stade
celles qui ont un effet ap inférieur à
20% ou 25%
c'est à dire on prend pas forcément tout
ce qui est significatif ici la religion
serait prise en compte mais ça permet de
faire déjà un premier tri de variables
ensuite on peut calculer notre modèle et
mettre tout notre modèle il mettre
toutes les variables dans le modèle et
on va voir qu'il est possible
après cela doit avoir une démarche pour
essayer de réduire le modèle si vous
vous souvenez quand on avait fait le
drop one je leur montre à l'écran nous
est donnée quand on retire une variable
le nom de degrés de liberté la variable
que l'on a retiré et
laval - les résidus qui découle inverse
de la variance expliquer ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que le groupe d'âge à
quatre modalités il est donc représentée
par trois coefficient il a donc un degré
dans le modèle de liberté de trois la
variable sexe et ordinaire elle est oui
non donc il ya un seul coefficient de
modèles donc un degré liberté de 1,1 des
objectifs c'est d'essayer de réduire le
nombre de degrés de liberté puisque si
on a un modèle plus parcimonieux on va
éviter des problèmes comme le sur
apprend le sueur a reprend le sur
apprentissage mais également vous aurez
un modèle qui serait un peu plus stable
et souvent de meilleure qualité
par contre à chaque fois que je retire
une variable on voit que mes résidus
augmente alors si je retiens le groupe
d'âge
il augmente de manière importante
puisqu'on passe de 2206 à 2259 alors que
si je retire la religion ça augmente
mais seulement un petit peu de 2002 111
ike que a proposé un critère qui
s'appelle la hisser qui tient compte à
la fois de la vraisemblance alors bon
choix dans la formule c'est le
logarithme de la vraisemblance mais
retenez que grosso modo ça tient compte
de la variance expliqué et du nombre de
degrés de liberté
donc l'idée c'est que selon l'indicateur
a hissé plus et a et c est petit
meilleur c'est si vous regardez ici la
hisser de base de mon modèle c'est lé
2236 8 6 je retire le groupe d'âge là et
seva ce minimiser parce qu'on retire des
décrets de liberté mais il va augmenter
parce que les résidus augmente et donc
du coup la laïcité parce 2236 à 2283
donc retiré groupe d'âge ferait
augmenter la hisser hors je vous le
rappelle selon ce critère là il faut
avoir le plus petit et c'est possible
par contre
si je retire la religion eh bien je vais
perdre un peu on va augmenter un peu les
résidus ce qui va faire monter la hisser
mais on va gagner 5 degrés liberté ce
qui va le faire baisser
et donc du coup là il sait passera à
2231 donc là il sait c'est un compromis
entre réduction du nombre de degrés
liberté et variant s'expliquer et donc
dans ce cas là on voit qu'un modèle sans
la religion sera un modèle meilleur que
le modèle de départ donc nous pouvons
retirer la religion de notre modèle pour
gagner sur la mini pour avoir un plus
petit a hissé la question c'est y at-il
encore d'autres variables à retirer
alors il ya une fonction qui permet très
facilement et très rapidement de faire
une simplification papa descendante du
modèle basé sur la i c'est la fonction
step
donc si je reviens ici je vais faire un
deuxième modèle que j'appelais mode deux
d'accord et pour ça je vais appliquer la
fonction step à mon premier modèle
donc ça sera tout simplement step de
mode exécutons tout ça alors je vais
vous d'abord vous présenter ce qu'on
voit s'afficher dans la console d'accord
donc on part de notre premier modèle qui
est sport groupe d'âge plus sexe plus
études plus religieux plusieurs tv et on
a donc un haïssez de 2000 236,80 step en
fait appel la fonction de roanne vous
retrouver ici la hisser et trie les
résultats en fonction de la hisser donc
ce qu'on voit c'est que là où on
minimise la hisser à cette étape c'est
en retirant religion c'est celle qui
permet d'obtenir le plus grand gain sur
la hisser step retire religieux du
modèle et on arrive à l'étape 2 donc à
cette étape là et c'est vos 2231 et le
modèle ces sports en fonction de groupes
d'âge plus sexe plus études plus leur tv
step rey appelle à nouveau la fonction
de points et on sait ce qui se passerait
si on retirait chacune de ces variables
une à une et tous les résultats sont
triés selon la hisser ce que l'on voit
c'est que le plus petit a hissé est
obtenir en ne faisant rien à cette étape
dès lors la fonction step s'arrête et
renvoie le dernier modèle obtenu mode 2
contient donc ce modèle-là sport en
fonction de groupes d'âge plus sexe plus
étude plusieurs tv
si par contre ça va dépendre de chaque
modèle dans certains cas on aurait
encore un gain à supprimer certaines
variables
si c'est le cas step retirer une
variable additionnel et continuerait la
démarche
donc on fait jusqu'à ce qu'on ait plus
de gains à retirer une variable
alors je reviens ici sur la présentation
puisque vous êtes 2 a demandé c'est quoi
le degré de liberté d'accord donc le
nombre de degrés de liberté
en langage un peu non technique
c'est le nombre de variables pour le nom
de coefficient du modèle d'accord pour
la variable leur tv il ya qu un seul
coefficient à calculer donc il ya un
degré liberté la variable sexe qui ne
verraient de type oui non et codée dans
le modèle sous la forme oui ou non
donc c'est un seul coefficient il n'y a
qu'une seule variable dans le modèle si
je m'intéresse à la variable groupe âge
je vous remonte le modèle le groupe
d'âge est codé avec 3 coefficient donc
le groupe d'âge est une variable
catégorielles à quatre modalités et
retenez qu'une variable à haisnes
modalités et codé avec elle - invariable
binaire plus spécifiquement il ya une
variable binaire qui associé à la
modalité 25 44 ans qui vaut 1
si la personne a entre 25 et 44 ans 0
sinon une variable binaire un de type 1
0 qui vaut ainsi on est dans la banalité
45 59 06 non une variable au binaire
associé à la modalité 60 ans et plus qui
vont 06 nom et pas de variables pour la
modalité de référence qui sont les 18-24
parce que si la personne à 18 24 ans
tout simplement c3 coefficients seront à
0,2 qu'on fait une variable
catégorielles à quatre modalités et
transformé en trois variables binaire on
reviendra dans quelques mois
plus en détail sur la manière dont on
peut coder les variables catégories et
dans un modèle ça en fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle un contraste de type traitement
c'est celui que vous verrez le plus
souvent dans les publications sciences
humaines et sociales ou en épidémiologie
en fait il ya différentes matières de
transformer une variable catégoriels
pour la mettre dans un modèle et on fera
une session dédiée aux différents
contrastes dans air mais retenir en tout
cas que cette variable 1 qui a quatre
modalités va appeler la qualité est
rentré dans le modèle sous forme de
trois variables binaire et c'est pour ça
qu'on dit qu'elle a trois degrés de
liberté plus il y a un coefficient de
termes différents dans un modèle plus ça
devient difficile de trouver le bon
équilibre entre tous les termes et de
trouver du et de faire en sorte que le
modèle convergent pour ça qu'on essaye
de réduire du coup le nombre de termes
dans un modèle alors on l'a vu la
fonction stop me permettrait rapidement
de simplifier mon modèle selon critères
de minimisation de la hisser de manière
générale minimiser selon l'asn revient à
peu près à retenir des variables
significative aux seuils de 15% alors
j'ai bien grosso modo mais en tout cas
la minimisation de la hisser c'est une
méthode parmi d'autres un certain se
base sur les pets valeurs qui fonctionne
bien qui est facilement accessible et
qui est une manière de simplifier le
modèle mode 2 qui est donc le résultat
de step de mode
c'est un modèle complet 1 et que je peux
utiliser la même manière dont je peux
faire par exemple mode 2 gg coeff modèle
et donc vous avez ici les coefficients
de ce deuxième modèle
voyez les coefficients pour l'âge pour
femmes pour le niveau d'études et pour
heures quotidiennes on peut avoir envie
de comparer les résultats du modèle
simple et du modèle complet donc on a
pour cela une fonction qui est gg coeff
comparé auquel on va pas si une liste de
modèles donc je vais faire listes et le
nom dans la liste vont donner les
étiquettes donc je vais appeler modèle
complet est égal à mode modèle simplifié
égale mode 2 pour que ce soit plus
visible
on va se mettre sur plusieurs lignes
donc voyez gg coeff comparé prend une
liste est donc une liste deux modèles
pour le coup et je vais juste donner un
nom à chacun des modèles et je vais
rajouter epône ans y est égale clos
puisque malgré tout ne pas oublier on
représente des adorations j'exécute et
voici les résultats je vais agrandir le
graphique
gkf compare un peu comparé 3 4 5 6
y a pas de limite sur le nombre de
modèles si ce n'est la lisibilité du
graphique
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que là le
modèle en rougir présenter le modèle
complet envers le modèle simplifié
donc on voit que dans le modèle
simplifié il n'y a pas de coefficients
pour la variable rapport à la religion
et puis on voit que de simplifier le
modèle ça ne change pas fondamentalement
les résultats par contre vous voyez
qu'il ya une des petites variations
c'est à dire que sur le fait d' âge il y
a un petit peu plus marquée par dont un
tout petit peu moins marquée dans modèle
simplifié sa dérision un petit peu près
plus proche du 1
mais sinon vous avez globalement des
résultats qui sont très similaires avec
mais à chaque fois forcément vous aurez
des petites variations sur les valeurs
exactes des coefficients gecov comparé
là vous avez une vue par défaut qui est
une vue dit dodge c'est à dire qu'on
vous a mis les coefficients les un côté
des autres il est aussi possible d'avoir
une vue côte à côte et qui se fait cette
fois c'est avec type égal f
pour faire ces petites et donc dans
cette variation de gégé coeff compare
cette fois ci on a une colonne pour le
modèle complet et une colonne pour le
modèle simplifié
voyez en fait les noms j'ai donné à gg
comme comparé mme sert juste en fait
pour nommer un mais deux modèles est
donc cette fois ci la couleur des points
correspond aux différentes variables et
on voit bien clairement il y 6 kg n'est
pas représenté donc vous avez en fait
des options avec gégé coeff comparé pour
facilement représenter les deux modèles
côte à côte et normalement vous pouvez
aussi faire un tableau de deux modèles
avec un que je me trompe pas tbl merde
je crois la fonction tibia en match qui
permet de fusionner deux tableaux et
juste pour vérifier il faut faire quoi
d'accord donc dans ce cas là on va on
retrouve la commande je vais vous la
mettre pour présenter les deux tableaux
côte-à-côte si on veut le faire
d'accord je vais faire un premier
tableau une qui va être mode tibet elle
brigue relation avec exponentielle et
quelques shows et un add global pi et je
vais rajouter admettions plusieurs
lignes pour ça tienne
et on va rajouter le hades estimates
donc je vous affiche ce que vous le
tableau t1 qui vient de calculer
donc ça c'était pour le modèle complet
je vais faire un deuxième tableau pour
le modèle simplifié donc mode 2 et
ensuite on va faire une fusion des deux
tableaux avec la fonction tibial merde
donc en fait je mets d'un de ici du de
l'exemple donc tbl metge tout d'abord il
faut que j'y passe une liste de tableau
à fusionner donc tibi égale liste à 2 t1
et t2 donc là j'ai fourni malice de
tableau à fusionner et tab
ces panneaux ne permet d'indiquer en
fait les titres des deux modèles donc et
pour les afficher en gras en fait faut
mettre juste des doubles étoiles donc le
premier ce sera un modèle complet et le
second modèle simplifié et on va
vérifier tout ça ça fonctionne
j'ai pas fermer ici up pour le g et
voyez j'ai bien ici un tableau avec mes
deux modèles côte à côte
peut-être que si je zoome on le verrait
un petit peu mieux vous avez le talent
au pro modèle complet et le tableau pour
le modèle simplifié et les variables ont
bien été associés ensemble
donc j tysabri là encore nous aide assez
facilement à présenter rapidement de
deux modèles côte à côte est alors
jamioulx posait une question qui est
comment faire si la variable que step
identifie à exclure du modèle est une
variable intérêts particulière dans le
modèle ou une variable statistiquement
significative alors d'une part c'est pas
possible qu'ils excluent une variable
statistiquement significative
comme je voulais dit quand on minimise
la hisser on est grosso modo à retenir
des variables qui ont un effet au moins
à 15 % donc une variable significative
quand on retire une variable
significative du modèle dé facto la
hisser augmenté donc ce n'est pas une
variable qui seraient exclues du modèle
par contre il est tout à fait possible
qu'il y a
qu'il y ait une variable particulière
parce qu'on veut tester cette variable
en particulier
et qu'elle sorte du modèle avec la
fonction step par exemple on pourrait
avoir la variable sexe or on aurait
inscrit tout notre analyse dans une
réflexion sur le genre avec des
hypothèses très forte sur les effets du
sexe sur notre variable d'intérêt est à
l'étape step sec seraient exclus dans ce
cas là je vous dirais il faudra intégrer
sexe dans votre modèle final puisque on
veut vérifier l'effet du sexe par une
fois qu'on contrôle sur les autres
effets mais parce que là notre question
porte spécifiquement sur le sexe est
bien dans ce cas là vous faites votre
step qui vous permet de retenir des
variables qui ont un effet vous repartez
du dernier modèle de step et vous
refaites ce modèle là avec la variable
sexe tout simplement
encore une fois il n'ya pas de ya pas de
manière unique de procéder ce qui compte
avant tout c'est la question vous vous
posez dans certains cas ça ne fait pas
sens de faire une simplification du
modèle par minimisation de la hisser ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
pratiques peuvent être différentes d'une
discipline à l'autre ou d'un champ à
l'autre en épidémiologie en économie ou
en sociologie on va pas toujours
procéder de la même manière et surtout
je vous dirais est ce qu'il ya un
intérêt dans certains cas il ya un
véritable intérêt à passer par une
procédure step parce qu'on a un intérêt
à isoler un nom plus réduite variable
dans d'autres cas on se pose une autre
question et parce qu'on se pose cette
autre question les variables que l'on
inclue dans le modèle vont être choisis
de manière un peu différente
il ya une question sur les hypothèses de
validité du modèle alors vraiment que
vous dans le cas d'un modèle de
régression logistique binaire il n'y a
pas à ma connaissance
l'hypothèse très forte sur la route
comme par contre il peut se poser la
question de la multi colline hérité mais
on n'abordera ça un petit peu plus tard
aujourd'hui et l'autre élément c'est
qu'on fait quand on fait un modem
et variées ont fait un peu l'hypothèse
que chaque variable un effet indépendant
des autres variables du modèle il dans
certains cas c'est pas vraiment le cas
et on va un terrain avoir besoin de
prendre en compte des effets
d'interaction ce qu'on va aborder juste
après
donc abordons la question des effets
d'interaction et pour bien comprendre ça
revenons sur sur notre modèle or je vais
repartir du modèle 2 1 qui est un petit
peu plus un mais regardons à nouveau
notre notre modèle 2 donc dans ce modèle
on a mis le groupe d'âge le sexe le
niveau d'études et le nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision
la question ce que l'on voit c'est qu'il
ya un effet d'âge et comme on a rentré
de manière indépendante l'âge et le sexe
dans le modèle on suppose qu'ils aient
un effet d'âge commun aux hommes et aux
femmes
non dans ce modèle tous les effets sont
indépendants c'est le but même de ceux
de ce type de modèle c2 de distinguer
les différents effets et donc on fait
l'hypothèse qu'ils aient un effet d'âge
qui va être équivalent chez les hommes
et chez les femmes de la même manière on
suppose qu'on a un effet du niveau
d'étude à sexe et groupes d'âge égale la
question et si je regarde les effets du
modèle on avait vu la semaine dernière
comment regarder les effets du modèle
avec pelote de haut les fêtes de mode 2
ce qui est une bonne manière de devoir c
est fait l'un
donc on a vu les hommes font plus de
sport que les femmes et comme c'est
rentrer de manière séparée on fait
l'hypothèse que c'était cette
distinction la sogc servent à chaque âge
et à chaque niveau d'études et pour
indépendamment du nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision
mais peut-être que
l'effet du sexe n'est pas le même à
chaque âge ou que l'effet de l'âge n'est
pas le même pour chaque sexe on peut
poser la question des deux manières dans
ce cas là on peut être intéressée pour
regarder s'il y a un effet d'interaction
entre la variable âgées la variable sexe
donc notre question c'est y at il un
effet d'interaction entre l'âge et le
sexe pour ça nous allons faire un
nouveau modèle j'ai appelé mode 3 donc
on cherche expliqué sport et je veux
mettre une interaction entre le sexe et
l'âge ce qui se représente en remplaçant
le plus par un multipliés et ont va
rajouter études
et rtv family égale binomiale a faim et
il faut bien sûr les données data égal
hdv 2003 je vais mettre ça sur deux
lignes pour plus de lisibilité
[Musique]
alors déjà la première petite chose
c'est qu'on prend ce que veut dire se
multiplier en fait multiplier ses
équivalents c'est une manière rapide en
fait d'écrire sexe plus groupage plus
sexe de poing groupage et je vous
expliquer ce que veut dire tout ça plus
études plus heures point tv autrement
dit quand on écrit sex trois groupes
d'âge on va rentrer et on va essayer de
mesurer l'effet du sexe d'une manière
autonome mais à retenir ça sera aux
modalités de référence à un effet du
groupe d'âge et l'interaction entre le
sexe et le groupe d'âge alors je vais
vous présenter
déjà les coefficients du modèle on va
faire un gecko f
deux modes 3 la difficulté avec les
interactions c'est de bien comprendre
comment interpréter les différents
coefficient donc là on a mis en place
une interaction entre le sexe et le
groupe d'âge d'accord et donc du coup
comme mon ami sexe plus ce groupe d'âge
plus sexe de poing groupe d'âge on a les
coefficients pour sexe les coefficients
pour groupes d'âge et les coefficients
de l'interaction ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que la leaf est que l'on regarde
ici d'accord c'est la probabilité donc
là il ya un effet supérieur pour les
hommes de faire du sport que pour les
femmes et ça c'est l'effet à la
référence du groupe d'âge
donc ça c'est l'effet d'être un homme
quand on a 18 24 ans sans suite vous
avez ici le coefficient qui sont les
effets de l'âge pour la modalité de
référence donc pour les femmes
d'accord donc pour les femmes
quand on a 25 44 ans il y a pas on fait
à peu près autant de sports que quand on
en a 18 24 entre 45 et 59
on commence légèrement à faire moins de
sport mais voyez on a un intervalle de
confiance un cerf assez large et quand
on a 60 ans et plus ont fait beaucoup
moins de sport qu'à 18 24 ans qu'à 25 44
ans ça c'est chez les femmes et enfin
voyez nous avons trois coefficient
additionnel qui sont les effets qui se
rajoute aux interactions autrement dit
le coefficient hommes 25 44
c'est l'effet qui se rajoutent pour les
hommes de 25 à 34 ans plus de l'effet
home chez les 18-24 et de l'effet femmes
chez les 25-44 ans et j'arrive à bien
bosser ce qu'il faut qu'on
prendre c'est que si j'ai un homme de 30
ans si j'ai un homme de 30 ans je vais
lui appliquer ce premier coefficient là
puis ce coefficient là puis ces
coefficients là donc c'est un effet
modificateurs par rapport à ces deux
situations là avec ce n'est pas facile
hein comme ça juste présenté de
comprendre de quoi on parle donc si je
vous dis est ce que les hommes de 25 44
ans font plus ou moins de sport que les
femmes de 25 44 ans là tout de suite je
pense que juste en regardant ça ne
pourrait pas me répondre
est ce que les hommes de 25 à 34 ans
font plus de sport que les femmes de 25
44 ans parce qu'en fait pour répondre à
ça il faut additionner ce truc là avec
ce truc là avec ce truc là et voir si
c'est plus grand plus petits coeurs
voyons voir le tableau 1
faisons mode 3,6 bielle donc là je suis
avec les coefficients j'ai pas mis le
exponentielle
donc je vais additionner donc hommes de
25 à 44 ans c'est donc 1,6 +0 06
- 1,2 d'accord donc pour un homme qui
est âgé de 25 44 ans je dois 10 youn et
tous ces coefficients pour voir la
différence par rapport à l'interceptent
si je prends une femme de 25 44 ans je
dois 10 youn et 0,06 donc 006 est
inférieure à 0 46 autrement dit les
hommes de 25 44 ans font plus de sport
que les femmes de même âge un donc ce
moins-12 ici peut être troublant c'est
parce que on doit à la fois faire le +16
+0 6 - 2 c'est pour ça que les
coefficients d'interaction parfois sont
un petit peu dur à comprendre
on a donc tout intérêt dans ces cas là
quand on a des interactions a
systématiquement au moins pour soi à
faire
le graphique des effets dont je vous
rappelle plaute hall effect 2 modes 3 ou
si on veut quelque chose d'un peu plus
propre avec gégé effect on l'avait vu
c'est ici avec gégé effect pilotes
copilotes
dans les deux cas on va voir les effets
donc regardons les effets marginaux du
modèle donc là ça nous fait des
prédictions puis on va prendre tous les
éléments on attendait
ah non j'ai fait ma séparer latence et
je fais mode 3 on va faire avec all
effect déjà pelote de all effect
voilà je vais zoomer disons retenez un
plateau les fake mode droit c'est celui
qui marche le mieux quand on va aller
vite et puis on s'embête a retrouvé la
syntaxe âge et j'ai fait quand on avait
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus joli
mais là on voit tout de suite ce qui
nous intéresse on allait fait des études
qu'on avait déjà vu deux heures tv c'est
celui ci qui m'intéresse c'est l'effet
d'interaction là ce que m'a fait hurler
facts vu qu'on avait mis une interaction
c'est qu'il a calculé d'accord les on à
la courbe parages chez les femmes et la
courbe barrage chez les hommes est donc
là on arrive à voir très facilement et
bien qu'à 25 44 ans les hommes ont
tendance à faire plus de sport que les
femmes non c'est une manière de se
représenter
plus finement ce qui est en train de se
passer donc pour avoir une bonne
une bonne visualisation toujours passer
par les effets en fait le prenne dans
les effets c'est de savoir interpréter
les coefficients parce qu'en fait si on
a des coefficients qui se multiplient où
s'additionnent les uns aux autres alors
une autre présentation graphique
uniquement de l'interaction je vais
rechercher dans mes notes
la syntaxe qu'on peut faire avec gégé
effect ces demandes déjà j'ai fait qd
spécifiquement le graphique d'une
certaine interaction longer prendre mode
4 pardon mode 3 donc gg effect et là je
vais indiquer sexe et groupage pourvoir
l'interaction entre les deux d'accord
donc j'y passe de nom de variables et là
du coup il va me calculait en fait
l'intérêt les effets d'interaction en
effet marginaux et pelote pourra voir le
graphique
alors là vous avez on voit le sexe à
droite à gauche et puis des couleurs
différentes pour l'âge pour avoir
peut-être quelque chose de plus lisible
je vais inverser les deux variables
voilà donc là vous avez du coulage
représenté en barre et puis les femmes
en rouge les âmes en bleu et là on voit
bien
du coup le différend effet c'est à dire
que les jeunes sont très nombreux relais
près des trois quarts à pratiquer du
sport avant 25 ans et donc du coup on a
une baisse importante avec l'âge pour
passer autour du car vers l'âge de 60
ans et les femmes enfin elles sont
finalement qu'un bon tiers à faire du
sport à 18 24 ans à ce maintien boire
même sac mon teint légèrement mais on
peut pas interpréter l'augmentation que
ça se maintient et 25 44 ans et donc du
coup ensuite ya une baisse mais une
baisse beaucoup plus modérée parce
qu'elles vont finalement
rejoindre les hommes donc là on voit
bien en tout cas qu'il ya une évolution
différente pour les hommes et pour les
femmes
mais si je reviens maintenant au
graphique des effets avec quelque chose
qui n'est pas toujours facile à
interpréter sur ces coefficients
d'interaction alors il ya une question
c'est peut-on dire que les effets
marginaux sont qui valent en effet de
relations ou est-ce qu'il s'agit surtout
d'une lecture plus fine des relations
très variable je pense qu'il faut le
voir comme un outil de lecture des
relations le principe un des effets
marginaux donc de ce type de graphique
c'est d'appliquer le modèle pour faire
des prédictions d'accord est ce que fait
effect il nous prédit qu est ce que dit
le modèle à la moyenne des autres
variables
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'ils il
nous fait une prédiction qui expliquait
en pourcentage d'accord donc le lannou
ce qu'on ait d'autres dans la dimension
du phénomène que l'on étudie donc en
fait c'est avant tout un outil dead à
l'interprétation et à comprendre ce que
veut le dire nos effets marginaux sur
tout et on va voir les effets marginaux
on l'avait déjà vu ne dépendez pas de la
modalité de référence en termes de
lecture et là je vais vous montrer
encore un autre petit effet une autre
manière d'écrire mon modèle dont j'ai
fait un nouveau modèle
sauf que je vais l'écrire différemment
je vais écrire uniquement sexe de poing
groupage d'accord vous voyez mon modèle
diffère parce que je n'aurai plus qu'un
effet d'interaction entre sexe et
groupage mais je n'aurai plus le
coefficient pour le sexe et de
coefficients pour le groupe d'âge
[Musique]
voyons voir les coefficients du modèle
donc en présentant les choses de cette
manière là on va avoir que les
coefficients sont codées différemment on
a toujours le coefficient pour
quotidienne et pour niveau d'études est
en fait je vais même vous dire les
coefficients qu'on voit là sont les
mêmes que tout à l'heure ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est sur la manière dont on
a des coefficients au lieu d'avoir des
commissions pour le sexe à la référence
de groupes d'âge puis les coefficients
du groupe d'âge à la référence du sexe
puis des modificateurs quand on n'est
pas la référence de l'un et de l'autre
ici vous avez un deux trois quatre cinq
six sept coefficient donc il ya un
coefficient qui n'est pas affichée à
l'écran qui est la référence des deux
donc la référence des deux se sont alors
c'est un petit peu différent il ya une
médiatique est pas présente ce sont les
hommes de 60 ans et plus donc la mode
était référence ici un tout petit peu
changé les voyages et femmes 18 24
hommes 18 24 femmes 25 44 hommes 25 44
femmes 45 59 hommes 45 69 59 femmes 60
ans et plus et donc du coup j'ai une
dernière modalité qui n'est pas présente
qui est sont les hommes de 60 ans et
plus
retenez là on a maintenant une référence
qui est homme de 60 ans et plus comme là
je suis pas en exponentiel manque
officiant simple il faut le voir sur le
zéro il est donc ce qu'on peut voir
c'est que les femmes de 60 ans et plus
font un peu moins de sport que les
hommes de 60 ans et plus mais ça peu
près équivalent les hommes de 45 59 ans
la cij procurer pour le sommes plus on
rajeunit plus on fait du sport
hélas si je prends mes points femme sa
remontée assez stable ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que du coup en faisant ça
quand tout à l'heure pour mes femmes
mes hommes de 25 de 30 ans j'avais trois
coefficient qui s'appliquait maintenant
je n'ai qu'un seul coefficient maximum
qui s'applique donc c'est un peu comme
si on avait en fait remplacé sexe et
groupes d'âge par une seule variable qui
sera le croisement des deux donc c'est
une autre manière de lire les
coefficients par contre est ce que ça a
changé nos effet jean photographique des
effets les effets sont tout à fait
identique
est ce que c'est un modèle différent
alors pour ça on va comparer les deux
modèles ont pour comparer deux modèles
on peut passer par la fonction à nova
alors attention la fonction à nova avec
une minuscule qu'est la fonction à nova
de stats qui permet de comparer deux
modèles ce qui est différent de hanau
avec une majuscule qui est celle de
quart qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure si
je fais à nova mode trois modes quatre
tests égale qui secouèrent et bien vous
verrez ce sont les mêmes modèles on
explique la même chose les modèles sont
vraiment identiques
et si on regarde bien on a toujours
cette coefficient on a le même nombre de
degrés de liberté c'est juste la manière
dont ces coefficients se combinant dans
un cas on avait eu des coefficients pour
les hommes et pour les femmes à la
référence femmes avec des coefficients
d'âge un coefficient de sexe à l'âge de
référence et puis après des
modificateurs c'est juste que les
commissions sont présentés différemment
la valeur des coefficients as interprété
différemment
par contre si vous regardez le graphique
des effets on a bien les mêmes résultats
c'est juste en fait qui s'additionnent
pas la même manière et on aurait même pu
faire un dernier modèle
je vais vous faire le modèle 5
j'aurais pu mettre une seule variable
dans le modèle dont j'ai fait un modèle
5 qui serait je sais pas - groupe âge
plus sexe deux points groupage donc si
je fais ce modèle je vous montre les
coefficients et donc dans ce cas là je
vais avoir des coefficients par groupe
d'âge 18 24 25 44 45 59 68 plus à la
référence de sexe donc pour les femmes
donc en fait là vous avez l'effet de
l'âge chez les femmes et du coup vous
avez ici des coefficients additionnel en
fait il ya trois coefficient qui font
sens 1 et là vous avez des coefficients
qui vous indiquent les modifications
chez les hommes
donc ça 18 24 hommes c'est la différence
c'est l'effet c'est la différence chez
les hommes par rapport aux femmes de 18
24 ans donc ça ça veut dire que les
hommes de 19,4 en font plus de sport que
les femmes 18 24 ans sont deuxièmes
coefficient là c'est la différence entre
les hommes de 25 44 ans et les femmes de
25 44 ans celui ci c'est la différence
entre les hommes de 45 59 ans et les
femmes de 45 59 ans et ça c'est la
différence entre les hommes de plus de
60 ans et les femmes de plus de 60 ans
donc en fait ce qui est compliqué dans
l'interaction c'est de bien savoir
interpréter je vous ai fait trois
modèles et dans ces trois modèles la qui
explique la même chose mais où les
coefficients sont différents parce qu'à
chaque fois des comparaisons différentes
dans le cas précédent comparer tous un
seul groupe
là les comparaisons ce fonds ont comparé
l'effet du sexe à chaque âge c'est
vraiment juste la manière de représenter
d'où le fait que ce regard des 1 les
effets du modèle
voyez on a encore le même graphique
parce que tous ces coefficients toute
façon arrive au même résultat est donc
là on voit bien on arrive beaucoup mieux
à comprendre ce que prédit le modèle la
question qui peut se poser c'est est-ce
que globalement il ya un effet de
l'interaction donc ce qu'on avait fait
tout à l'heure je vais vous faire le
tableau du modèle trois modes 3 tbl
relation et je vais rajouter had global
pays
[Musique]
donc là on nous dit qu'il ya un effet
global de la variable sexe un effet
global de la variable groupes d'âge et
en plus il ya un effet global de
l'interaction sexe fois groupes d'âge on
peut retrouver ça si je fais quart de
point à nova mode 3g
l'effet de l'interaction l'effet de
l'âge et l'effet du sexe on peut avoir
des cas de figure où il ya un effet de
chacune des variables mais pas de leurs
interactions
je peux faire aussi sur mode 4 alors là
c'est un peu différent ce que dans votre
4g mis qu'une interaction et donc du
coup j'ai qu'un effet global de sexe
groupe d'âge mais sans avoir distingué
les effets des deux variables
indépendantes
donc du coup dans certains cas on pourra
regarder si globalement l'interaction à
porte ou parle dans certains cas de
figure on va se rendre compte que il y a
des effets de deux variables mais si
elles sont vraiment indépendante leurs
interactions ne devrait pas avoir
d'effet est ce que j'ai un autre exemple
à vous proposer
excusez moi à oui on peut faire un autre
exemple et vous faire un modèle
regardez l'interaction entre le sexe et
le niveau d'études
d'accord donc on va faire un nouveau
modèle donc cette fois ci on va faire
une interaction sexe étoiles études
donc ça va devenir un modèle 6 je vous
montre le graphique du modèle déjà on va
regarder les effets pelote hall effect
mode 6
donc là on voit qu'il ya un effet du
niveau d'études mais qui a l'air un
petit peu similaire quand même entre
entre chez les hommes et chez les femmes
si je leur présente de manière plus fine
1 ce que j'ai fait que nous permet de le
faire l'un sur l'autre
donc là ses études voyez les
coefficients sont quand même à peu près
les mêmes chez les hommes et chez les
femmes avec bon un petit et une petite
différence ici sur manquant sur
secondaire et un peu des cas mais chez
primaire supérieure ou technique
professionnelle c'est à peu près le même
effet chez les hommes et chez les femmes
et donc du coup on pourrait regarder
est-ce que l'interaction apporte quelque
chose à mon modèle et si vous regardez
ici et bien on a un fort effet du groupe
d'âge un effet important du sexe un
effet important du niveau d'étude par
contre l'interaction sexe études alors
elle est en effet on est à 2 07 % donc
le petit paix sous les 5% on pourrait
maintenir l'interaction mais la question
c'est de savoir si ça apporte grand
chose
on voit qu quand on a des interactions
c'est plus compliqué à expliquer les
différents modèles et donc du coup on
n'y gagne pas forcément du point de vue
narratif
je pense que quelque chose qui est
important notamment dans le domaine des
sciences humaines et sociales
c'est aussi le pense est votre modèle
sur comment est-ce qu'on va comment est
ce qui donne sens au phénomène que l'on
étudie alors la question c'est à ton
intérêt à tester toutes les interactions
alors le problème c'est que des
interactions il y en a beaucoup
parce que là je pourrai regarder toutes
les interactions entre le groupe d'âge
le sexe le niveau d'étude le rapport à
la religion et le nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision
mais on pourrait aussi faire des
interactions à trois niveaux
je pourrais vous faire un modèle je vais
appeler
le modèle fou où je vous fais
l'interaction entre le groupe d'âge sexe
le niveau d'études et le nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision
[Musique]
alors déjà il n'a pas réussi à converger
donc il peut y avoir des résultats qui
sont pas très bon on va essayer de
retirer juste heurté vais peut-être vous
voyez quand il ya trop d'interaction il
ya trop coefficient il pour arriver à
converger et je vous montre les modèles
doit pas manger coeff modèle dérivé du
modèle avec toutes les interactions donc
déjà le modèle a pas réussi à converger
apparemment assez de données il n'a pas
réussi voyons voir juste combien être
efficient là dedans si j'affiche à la
console retient des manquants et voyez
toutes les combinaisons de variables que
ça fait en fait ça revient limite à
calculer à croiser tous avec tous donc
non on peut pas tester toutes les
interactions en général c'est pas très
bon et on n'y gagne pas grand chose
alors certains ont des approches qui
vont tester toutes les interactions 2 à
2,1 pas les interactions niveau 3 et 4
mais uniquement toutes les interactions
2 à 2 et paris toutes les mettre dans le
même modèle l'on pourrait faire juste un
modèle avec les interactions une par une
et puis après les mettre dans le modèle
ça peut être très long très redondant et
pas forcément apporté grand chose
j'ai envie de dire tout dépend de
l'analyse qu'on fait dans certains cas
par exemple si j'ai une analyse qui est
très fortement parle aussi je n'avais
vraiment qu'ils s'intéressent à des
effets de genres très marqué peut-être
que j'aurais intérêt à tester toutes les
interactions du genre avec les autres
variables et voir lesquels ont un effet
significatif
peut-être que je vais orienté certaines
interactions par rapport à ce que je
vais anticipé mais tout et c'est avec
tout c'est difficilement réaliste mettre
toutes les interactions même temps on
n'arrive pas vraiment à converger et
donc du coup je vous dirais plutôt de se
dire quelles sont les interactions qui
font sens à aller tester et puis mieux
vaut un modèle avec pas ou peu
d'interactions et qu'ils soient bien
interpréter et sur lequel on fera un bon
travail que de vous la faire un modèle
très compliqué mais qui sera mal
interprété et sur lequel les résultats
seront seront se rendent deux seront
mauvaise qualité
plus on en rajoute plus on complexifie
fortement le modèle
alors je vous propose d'aborder
rapidement je le fais vraiment
rapidement la question de la
multipolarité dans l'est dans la
régression
probablement parce que c'est quelque
chose dont vous allez entendre entendre
parler soit on vous dit à de vérifier si
vos variable ne sont pas multi
colinéaires et souvent il ya une
confusion sur qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
multi colline hérité donc je vous
propose plutôt une présentation rapide
sur cette question là pour vous ramener
ensuite tranquillement à relire le
chapitre dédié sur sur analyseur en fait
on parle de multi co linéarité lorsque
plusieurs variables mesure la même chose
et dans ce cas là ça peut être
problématique car elle peut augmenter
elle prend en fait certains coefficient
instable alors deux choses à retenir
c'est qu'on va voir c'est la multi
colina rites et ne veut pas dire que ce
sont des variables corrélés et souvent à
vous entendre et par des des gens vous
dire il faut pas mettre des variables
corrélés dans le modèle c'est pas tout à
fait ça on va voir ce qu'il faut c'est
ne pas avoir de variables multi
collinaires alors avoir des variables
multiples linéaire à ça peut créer
les prem's suivant certains coefficient
peuvent sembler non significatif alors
qu'il ya bien une relation significative
entre un prédicteur et sa réponse les
coefficients de prédicteurs fortement
corrélé varieront considérablement d'un
échantillon à l'autre et donc du qu'on
peut avoir des effets qui vont être
absorbées tantôt par une variable tantôt
par une autre et lorsque les termes d'un
modèle sont fortement corrélés la
suppression de la détermination dans ce
considérable sur les autres termes c'est
pour ça qu'on dit il faut faire
attention la multipolarité mais en fait
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la multi
co linéarité n'a aucune incidence sur
l'adéquation du modèle aucune incidence
sur la qualité de la prévision est en
fait d'un incident ce qu entre les
variables qui sont multi colinéaires ça
n'affecte pas les autres variables du
modèle alors
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on
appelle multi colline est arrêtée au
sens strict on parle de multi co
linéarité parfaite lorsque l'une des
variables explicatives d'un modèle est
une combinaison linéaire d'une ou
plusieurs autres variables explicatives
introduite dans le même modèle est une
des conditions requises pour estimer un
modèle linéaire et par extension un
modèle linéaire généralisée c'est
l'absence de multi co linéarité parfaite
alors un exemple concret de multi
colonna rite est parfaite c'est
typiquement le problème de l'âge de la
période est de la génération 6 dans un
modèle supposons que vous avez un modèle
d observation à différents points dans
le temps et que dans le même modèle vous
ayez comme variable date d'observation
date de naissance de l'enquêté et h de
l'enquêté vous aurez un problème en
mettant les 3 pourquoi parce que l'âge
de la personne enquêtée est égale à la
date d'observation - la date de
naissance
donc en fait il en peut écrire une
relation à sous forme de relation
linéaire entre plusieurs variables c'est
ce qu'on appelle la multipolarité
autrement dit une variable et expliquer
qu'on est totalement expliquée par
d'autres variables présente dans le
modèle donc ça c'est le cas parfait
c'est qu'en fait on dit trois fois la
même chose à partir du moment où j'ai
d'adolescence et d'adopter rva sion je
peut en déduire automatiquement l'âge
donc je ne peux plus mettre l'agent
modèles dont sur ces trois variables
il faut en effet choisir deux mais on
peut pas mettre les trois d'un coup
elles sont multi collinaires et donc
dans ce cas là ce que si on met les
trois mais bien les effets seront
capturés tantôt par l'une tantôt par
l'autre mais en fait on savait pas dire
que l'une rien n'y fait pas l'autre
c'est comme elle se représente la même
chose les coefficients sont instables
entre ces trois variables
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut remettre
que deux sur les trois un autre exemple
serait d'étudier la mortalité infantile
on s'intéresse à deux choses est-ce que
la maternité où on a accouché
est-ce que donc la maternité située en
ville ou en milieu rural et deuxièmement
est ce que elle est dirigée par un
médecin ou par une infirmière
supposons qu'on est dans un pays où bas
la plupart des médecins qui dirige les
maternités sont plutôt en ville parce
qu'ils veulent pas aller à la campagne
d'accord donc c'est à dire que 70% des
matin les médecins quand il dirige une
maternité c'est pour 70% des matières
étaient en ville et que du coup quand
s'est dirigée par une infirmière c'est
pour 60% des maternités en milieu rural
donc il ya une forte corrélation entre
eux mix entre le le le type de
directeurs médecins ou infirmières et le
milieu de résidence urbain ou rural
cependant on a bien des médecins qui lie
à des maternités en ville et à la
campagne
de même que pour les infirmières donc on
peut essayer dans le modèle de séparer
les faits du type de directeur l'effet
du type de directeur et les faits
donc l'effet du type directeur pardon et
l'effet du milieu de résidence dans ce
cas là
dans ce cas là les deux variables sont
bien corrélé mais elles ne sont pas
multi colinéaires un savoir si c'est un
médecin ou une infirmière ne permet pas
de savoir si on est en ville ou à la
campagne ce qui serait plus
problématique c'est si jamais tous les
médecins travaillaient en ville et qu'on
serait dans la situation où tout les
martyrs ural serait dirigée par une
infirmière et tandis que les maternités
urbaine se diriger seraient dirigés ou
para médecin ou par une infirmière dans
ce cas là si on sait que c'est un
médecin et balance et defacto qu'on est
en milieu urbain et donc du coup on aime
multi colline hérité pas parfaite mais
oui on mesure un peu deux fois la même
chose on aurait plutôt intérêt à
transformer ces deux variables là en une
seule variable ternaire qui serait rural
urbain infirmières urbain médecin donc
voilà le à retenir le problème de la
multi colline vérité c'est quand on a
plusieurs variables qui mesurent la même
chose et ça peut être fier simplement
parce que certains phénomènes sont sont
associées de manière directe ou
indirecte
alors peut-on mesurer la multi co
linéarité il ya différentes approches
qui existe est la plus classique en fête
consiste à examiner ce qu'on appelle les
facteurs d'inflation de la variance
écrivait et en anglais on parle de
vaillance une flèche de factor ou vf
alors la lessive et estime de combien la
variance d'un coefficient est augmenté
en raison d'une relation linéaire avec
d'autres prédicteurs et donc du coin et
fives et de 1,8 nous dit que la variance
de ce coefficient particulier supérieur
de 80 % la variance que l'on aurait dû
observer si ce facteur était absolument
pas corrélées aux autres grosso modo ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que quand les
vifs sont proches de 1
il n'y a pas de multi colinia rites et
voilà
et si les vifs sont un peu trop élevé on
peut avoir un problème
première chose déjà les
vif en tant que tel ça se calcule
uniquement pour des variables numérique
mais il existe une définition qu'on
appelle et general la ffg vif qui
peuvent s'adapter à des variables
catégorielles pour ça on peut avoir
recours à la fonction vif du package
car donc on va calculer on va regarder
si on apprenne de multi colinière était
dans notre modèle
donc on va repartir sur le tout premier
modèle le modèle mode et donc je vais
appliquer quart de point vif
donc n'oubliez pas un
cette syntaxe veut dire la fonction vif
du package cas alors ce que vous voyez
vous voyez deux choses vous voyez le g
vif qui est donc cet cette version
généralisée du vif et puis certains
auteurs considèrent lorsqu'on a des
variables catégorielles qui ont du coup
plusieurs degrés de liberté il y aurait
une correction à appliquer aux jets vif
et vous l'avez ici alors la question
c'est est-ce que c'est proche de 1 ou
pas et à partir de combien faut
s'inquiéter
là on voit tous nos vifs sont en dessous
de 2 alors tous les auteurs sont pas
d'accord certains auteurs disent qu'il
faut regarder plus en détail les
variables avec un f iv est supérieur à
2,5 tandis que d'autres s'inquiètent
qu'à partir de 5
il faut savoir qu'il ya aucun test
statistique qui nous dit ainsi le vif
est trop élevée ou pas élevé donc on a
pas de paix valeurs qu'on pourrait
utiliser on a juste un lift d'accord et
je vous dirai ce que ya prés ou pas
problèmes alors nous en l'occurrence on
a rien qui dépassait deux et demi est-ce
que
et sinon si vous voyez des choses qui
commença à bout de rapprocher deux
ennemis 3 vous regardez un peu plus en
détails
posez vous la question et si vraiment
c'est supérieur à 5 inquiétez-vous dans
les faits je vous avouerai je regarde
pas systématiquement les vifs sur les
modèles par contre j'ai en général déjà
réfléchi aux variables que je mettais
dans mon modèle et j'ai anticipé les
risques potentiels de multi que la
vérité parce que je sais des variables
après faut savoir qu'il ya un vrai débat
donc je vous dirais que sur la multi
colline hérité il n'y a pas de position
tranchées unique et identique pour tout
le monde
on a des relations un peu différente
suivant les auteurs et n'hésitez pas
aussi à voir quels sont les usages plus
spécifiques dans votre discipline 1 ou
dans votre champ ou dans les revues dans
lequel vous voulez publier ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la multiculti co
linéarité et pas toujours un problème le
problème par exemple si vous si d'accord
ce qui vous intéresse avant tout c'est
de savoir l'effet du sexe sur le sport
c'est pas grave si une multi colline
hérité entre les autres variables du
modèle je pourrais avoir par le multi
colline hérité entre le groupe d'âge le
niveau d'études
à la limite ça serait pas grave pourquoi
parce que la multi colline hérité fait
il ya une instabilité on sait pas trop
si les effets vont être choper par le
groupe d'âge ou par le niveau d'études
mais ça change en rien les effets qu'on
mesure sur le sexe donc si le but
premier du modèle c'est surtout de
regarder la relation entre le sexe et le
sport et que les autres variables sont
là juste pour faire du contrôle il n'y a
pas trop
il n'y a pas trop d'inquiétudes à avoir
on peut aussi avoir un autre cas de
figure où il n'y a pas trop à
s'inquiéter c'est quand on met des
variables quantitative avec leur carré
alors typiquement là je vous ai vu dans
nous dans le modèle on a mis l'âge
regroupés en catégorie d'âge les
économistes auraient peut-être plutôt
tendance à mettre l'âge de manière
continue plus l'âge au carré quand on
met la géla jo car il n'y a absolument
pas de problème de le faire dans votre
dans votre modèle mais vous risquez
d'avoir une auto corrélation entre les
deux et donc voilà ça c'est pas
forcément très très très problématique
en soi juste pour vous dire que il n'ya
pas consensus si à un moment donné la
question la multi que la vérité vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à les revoir le
chapitre sur un analyseur ou à un moment
donné vous trouverez quelques références
de certains auteurs en fait là ce que je
vous présente c'est déjà une traduction
d'un auteur il ya pas énormément de
d'auteurs qu'on publier des billets
assez simple sur cette question là et
puis juste vous dire de plus que sur la
multi co linéarité sur le calcul des
vifs dans la prochaine version de jti
samarie donc ça n'est pas encore le cas
dans celle actuelle mais il y aura une
fonction à de vifs
donc at vif on pourrait appliquer sur un
tableau sera disponible dans la
prochaine version de jean marie je vois
qu'il est déjà 18h30
ça me semble difficile d'aborder un les
régressions multi nomia les la
régression ordinale on fera ça sur une
prochaine séance pour avoir un peu plus
de temps ce que je vais vous proposer
malgré tout c'est de reprendre quand
même un peu de temps pour revenir sur
cet opus est cette fonctionnalité que
vous avez présenté la semaine dernière
qui dans la dernière version de leur
studio la 1.4 de pouvoir compilé un
script en rapport donc on l'a vu on si
tout mon code si mon script peut se
dérouler par lui-même c'est-à-dire que
mon script qui incorpore notamment le
chargement des paquets de gens j'ai
besoin et le chargement est là le
chargement l'import de mes données
je peux donc le script est autonome et
s'exécute de lui même je peux le faire
rapidement un rapport au format word ou
html il suffit de cliquer sur ce petit
bouton et de choisir le format
donc attention vous avez trois formats
html pdf word comme je sais que certains
ont posé la question je sais que
certains ont essayé de faire un rapport
au format pdf et qu'ils ont et des
messages d'erreur pour convertir au
format pdf vous devez impérativement
avoir installé en parallèle une
distribution de la tec sur votre pc ou
votre mac ou votre ordinateur linux
si vous êtes sous windows une des
distributions les plus connus c'est la
distribution milk tech mais en soit
l'installation de latex et pas forcément
une chose simple donc si vous êtes un
peu à l'aise avec l'installation de
programmes compliqué oublié
oubliez en tant que tel de faire une
sortie au format pdf vous pouvez du coût
privilégié soit une sortie au format
html ou une sortie au format word qui ne
nécessite pas d'avoir installé un outil
supplémentaire sur votre ordinateur
pour rappel un là je viens de lancer
dons sard exécute tout le script et on
va voir le code apparaître donc cela
j'ai demandé un format html plutôt qu'un
format word parce que ça un format plus
générique et on peut ensuite de la page
web copier les images pour les pour les
pour les reconvertir ou copier
directement le tableau si on veut le
récupérer ailleurs voyez que ça met un
petit peu de temps puisqu'en fait il
exécute ou le script donc c'est normal
qu'on attende parfois une ou deux
minutes parfois plus sur des grosses
analyse
elana rang
toujours un peu gourmand c'est en cours
là j'entends le pc est en train de
chauffer
je vois qu'il a d'ailleurs qu'on il ya
certains fichiers temporaires qui sont
inscrits dont on parle de l'analyse
pratique sport sacrés temporairement un
deux fichiers analyse patrick sport
point spin point spin pour les rênes dès
qu'ils sont en fait en cours de
conversion et à la toute fin
j'obtiendrai du coup un fichier analyse
pratiquer ce sport et la voyez c c'est
en train de s'exécuter et on obtient du
coup lui ficher finale alors si vous
regardez par défaut le titre du fichier
basse et le nom officier d'origine 1 il
a essayé déterminé mon automatiquement
simon utilisateurs sur l'ordinateur
la date du jour et puis on a une mise en
forme assez basique mais il est possible
de personnaliser un petit peu le rendu
alors pour cela si vous cherchez dans
google r studio compagne oui pauthe
[Musique]
on va trouver l'article sur le site de
la studio qui nous présente du coup
cette nouvelle fonctionnalité d'accord
et on nous explique qu'il est possible
de personnaliser certains paramètres
avec des commentaires un peu particulier
voiliers qui sont diez
guillemet simple donc ces commentaires
permettent de changer notamment le titre
et le document est le format du document
donc si je reviens ici au tout début
donc je copie ça il faut bien garder un
les trois tirs est la date je la laisse
et en automatique mais je vais mettre
auteur joseph la marange et titre
analyse de la pratique du sport
hdv 2003 de même si je reviens à la page
documentation on nous explique qu'on
peut mettre un peu de marques
d'informatique donc pour ceux que ça
intéresse et qui veulent à l'occasion
apprendra puisqu'elle marque daun jeu
vous allez 8 allée voir sur l'analyse
airs ou sur internet mais ça permet de
de faire des commentaires un peu
particulier l'étape d'après un c'est
d'arriver sur des vrais documents et
remarques down qui permet d'aller plus
loin sur la mise en forme mais en fait
ça va nous permettre nous d'inclure
quelques titres retenez qu'on est sur
des commentaires un peu spécifique qui
sont im point de pardon les guillemets
simple donc si je reviens ici je vais
pouvoir deux des grands titres
donc sachez que faire un titre de niveau
un an marc down c'est avec le dies que
ça se fait donc je vais faire je vais
voir si ça marche et si je vais dire du
coup mise en place
analyse univariée alors il faut que je
remette les tirer pour être reconnu dans
le système interne
et là je vais m diez régulation
logistique et on va relancer le calcul
juste pour voir si ça change quelque
chose sur les résultats je vous avoue
c'est après il faut que je teste c'est
une nouvelle fonctionnalité des
compagnies pauthe
on va attendre les deux trois minutes
mais normalement en fait ça devrait au
moins organisés en quelques grands
titres et permettre de rajouter des
éléments additionnels
pendant que ça calcule ceci dit retenir
une chose 1-2 base fait déjà essayé de
faire en sorte que vous ayez un script
qui fonctionne tout seul de début de but
en blanc et vous puissiez faire votre
rapport et puis petit à petit quand vous
avez du temps commencé à essayer de
découvrir d'autres fonctionnalités pour
rendre vos rapports un petit peu plus
esthétique et puis au moment où vous
vous sentirez n'hésitez pas à vous
tourner carrément vers les rapports
hermary down qui est l'outil qui permet
de faire des rapports les plus poussées
mais comme toujours pour tous ces outils
là il suffit en fait d'apprendre
progressivement injuste étape par étape
voilà deux de voir comment est-ce qu'il
fonctionne alors on va juste vérifier le
rendu ça y est ça se calcule
et donc là la nouveauté voyez le titre
que j'ai mis au tout début donc dans
cette partie 1 qui est à cette section
avec les 3-1 avant et après qu'une
section du groupe pour les métadonnées g
indiquer un titre
un auteur est bien dans le résultat le
titre et l'auteur ont été mis à jour
la date elle est mise de manière
automatique et la voyez ici où j'ai mis
simplement mises en place donc avec
cette syntaxe un peu particulière c'est
interprété comme un titre de niveau 1 et
d'envoyer j'ai commencé à des grands
titres qui permettent alors ici ça pas
été pris mais qui permettent du coup de
d'avoir un petit peu de mise en forme
dans votre dans votre rapport final donc
je vous renverrai l'élément complet mais
donc mon titre de niveau 2 c'est celui
ci a voilà j'ai oublié le dièse et enfin
devait la partie
voilà vous voyez en fait là c'est quand
on écrit des commentaires y commence par
dièse apostrophe on peut écrire en fait
le texte et remarques down on l'a pas
encore vu on vous le reverrez un peu
plus tard voilà vous pouvez aller
regarder sur internet si ça vous
intéresse vous trouverez de nombreux on
peut trouver de très nombreux tutoriels
sur sur le r marc down d'une part sur le
site analyse r vous avez un chapitre
ceux à marques de manière plus générale
sur une introduction aux rapports
automatisés
donc quiconque abordera dans une
prochaine session et puis si vous
intéresser aux marques down proprement
dit donc il ya deux choses le macd aoun
qui a un langage de balisage léger et le
1er mars down qui est du marc down avec
du r dedans mais sur le mark damon vous
pouvez trouver énormément de deux sites
qui vous expliquent qu est ce que le
mark damon et comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'écrire
voilà donc c'est des choses qui vont
pouvoir arriver mais voyez l'idée c'est
d'un balisage légers par exemple en
marque down on a indiqué du gras par des
doubles étoiles je suis un texte rédigé
en étoiles et toiles markdown étoiles et
toiles et ça deviendra je suis un texte
rédigé en marque town markdown mis en
gras donc là c'est donc c'est une
syntaxe assez simples qui permettent de
faire de la mise en forme tout ça
dites-vous 1 que ce sont des choses que
vous ayez à intégrer petit à petit
quoi qu'il en soit pour aujourd'hui nous
avons vu voilà nous nous avons quand
même pu aborder
les points principaux sur la régression
logistique en deux séances la semaine
prochaine nous aurons une séance un peu
particulière je vous propose une séance
de questions réponses où là vous pouvez
préparer en amont vos questions venir
avec elle
et du coup on se rassure zoom donc on
pourra parler en direct et vous pourrez
aussi partager vos écrans qu'on voit
bien où sont les problèmes que vous
rencontrez
donc si une seule 6,6 à pardon si ce
n'est pas encore le cas
pensez à vous rendre sur le site des
webinaires et à vous inscrire à la
mailing-list
en envoyant le subscribe webinar à saint
patrice poingt ird et point fr et pour
être abonné à la mailing list et
recevoir du coup les codes d'accès zoom
pour la semaine prochaine
et puis je donc ça sera la semaine du 11
février
et je vais vous préparé un programme
pour février mars mais de toute façon
nous allons dans les prochaines semaines
revenir du coup bien sûr déjà la gestion
des données pondérées les plan
d'échantillonnage complexe et notamment
le paquet je servais on aura du coup une
session sur la régression logistique
multi nominal et ordinale on viendra du
coup sûr leur marque dawn dont je vous
ai parlé et à la mise en forme de
tableau avec jti les câbles en
particulier surtout on va revenir sur le
dj pelote de la grammaire des graphiques
et revenir vraiment sur les bases jugé
pelote et comment faire des graphiques
plus poussée on abordera aussi des
choses un peu plus un peu plus avancées
en terme de manipulation de données
comme la gestion des tattes de choses
qu'on n'a pas encore vu et surtout au
travers d'outils avec l'analyse de
survie l'analyse et correspondances
multiples ou la classification
ascendante hiérarchique
je ne sais pas encore dans quel ordre
toutes les séances vont se mettre en
place je reviendrai du coup
prochainement avec un avec un programme
pour les prochaines sessions dans tous
les cas je vous souhaite pour le moment
une
une bonne fin de journée on se
retrouvera du coup très prochainement
pour un prochain webinaire et la semaine
prochaine sur zone et je vous envoie les
liens dans le courant de la semaine
merci à vous et très très bonne journée
au revoir